this is Timothy young a New Mexico
resident who was pulled over by the
Deming Police Force in 2012 for nothing
more than allegedly failing to use a
turn signal it started out as a minor
traffic stop but the next 14 hours would
turn into a humiliating violation of a
New Mexico man's body by police and
doctors Young was subjected to a series
of invasive anal procedures that failed
to turn up any contraband why did such a
minor infraction lead to an anal probe
the search was carried out on the hunch
of this officer Leo the dog dubious
instances involving canines are both
frequent and deeply troubling if you are
cop and you have a dog all you have to
do is claim the dog alerted and you can
search any car you want Jacobs solemn is
a senior editor Reason magazine who's
written extensively about canine misuse
the power of the police dog basically
begins with the assumption that they
don't make mistakes
dogs do have a superhuman ability to
smell stock there's no question about
that they really do it has to be a
properly trained raw dog and it has to
be used properly so you can't simply
conclude based on the fact that dogs
have this well-known ability to smell
stuff that humans can't smell that any
old dog is going to be able to do this
this is Andy Falco a former police
officer and k-9 handler for the Anaheim
Police Department in California law
enforcement sometimes gets a idea of who
they're criminals are in their
particular City they will motivate their
dog or cue their dog to alert when
there's absolutely nothing there Falco
then demonstrated how easy it is for
cops to manipulate a dog to gain access
to your vehicle
merit search and then they get to a
point where they want the dog to sit in
the back of the vehicle what are you
good again very easy the dog never smelt
the narcotics the dog never sniffed the
car and now of course you can
say my dog alerted on your car and then
they go that's enough for us and they go
inside the vehicle there are no uniform
standards for training the dogs or for
training the trainer many departments do
their own training so they set their own
standards one of the cases the Supreme
Court heard last year involved that very
question what does it mean to say the
dog is properly trained and they
basically ended up saying it if the
police department says he's properly
trained it's okay for judges to assume
that that's true in the absence of
evidence to the contrary Solem points
out that the accuracy of drug sniffing
dogs is anything but a settled matter
a 2011 analysis by the Chicago Tribune
of suburban police departments found
that searches justified by a dog's alert
failed to turn up drugs 56 percent of
the time recent studies done by
government inspectors in Australia found
false positives of 74 percent and 80
percent yet a 2013 Supreme Court ruling
insists that a court can presume that a
dog's alert provides probable cause to
search of course the police department
is going to say their dog is well
trained of course the reason why they
might want a dog that was not that well
trained is if you have a dog that will
alert on cue or alerts promiscuously
just at random that's a very useful tool
for you to be able to search people that
you have other grounds to think are
suspicious I think there's an issue
sometimes with the training some
handlers in small departments don't have
the budget to contract with somebody to
get the training that they need they
perhaps maybe train the dog to find some
odors but they don't give all the
information that's necessary they don't
teach the handler how to be effective
I've seen cases where somebody trained
their own dog in their backyard and they
take it to work and use it as a drug dog
that actually exists that happens
preventing future cases of police abuse
isn't the only reason law-enforcement
officials need to set up new standards
for how police dogs are used canines
when used properly make a safer
just like a car just like the gun a dog
is a necessary tool for every Police
Department because they're that
effective the problem is we're going to
lose them because we're not using them
the way that we're supposed to